nous sommes en pleine révolution une
révolution technologique
une révolution numérique
une révolution qui a 60 ans une
révolution autoproclamé peut-être comme
les humanistes du quattrocento se
disaient d'eux mêmes rina cheetah la
renaissance c'est aussi une révolution
comme par exemple pour le philosophe
michel serres
une révolution culturelle et cognitives
comprenant que cette révolution change
notre représentation du monde qu'elles
changent les relations entre nous et
qu'elle change peut être même notre
relation à nous mêmes c'est là où j'ai
un doute
pas une nostalgie les italiens disent à
quoi passa pas notre match in a few
il ne s'agit pas de revenir en arrière
l'eau qui est passée n'alimente plus le
moulin mais c'est un doute et une
incertitude sur ce qui est vraiment
moderne puisque dans une révolution il
ya forcément une modernité c'est à dire
un avant et un après alors c'est cette
incertitude que je voudrais maintenant
partager avec vous mais en y invitant
aussi de vieilles idées pour ça je vous
parlerai de modernité politique de
modernité économique et de modernité
scientifique dans notre modernité
politique on entend souvent aujourd'hui
que nos libertés s'accroissent nos
libertés s'accroissent parce que nous
pouvons échanger beaucoup plus
d'informations qu'avant et beaucoup plus
rapidement nos libertés s'accroissent
aussi parce que nous sommes beaucoup
plus en relation en temps réel et aux
quatre coins du monde
d'ailleurs certains disent que lors du
printemps arabe et du renversement des
régimes autoritaires les réseaux sociaux
ont joué un grand rôle
en parallèle nos données personnelles et
notre vie privée sont commercialisés des
sociétés comme facebook ou google vives
de la commercialisation de notre vie
privée
c'est même sûrement la première fois
dans l'histoire de l'humanité que la vie
privée est cotée en bourse car c'est ce
que je sais c'est ce dont il s'agit avec
google et facebook ça effectivement
c'est une nouveauté
pour commercialiser notre vie privée il
faut nous surveiller et il faut nous
surveiller en masse et en permanence
autrement dit à chaque fois que nous
nous connectons avec un ordinateur
standard tablette ou portable peu
importe cela implique que nous soyons
surveiller nos faits et gestes
numériques sont tous traités collectées
et analysées afin d'être revendu en ce
sens nous serions une forme de liberté
surveillée
une liberté surveillée qui impliquerait
que nous au lieu de porter un bracelet
électronique qu'un juge nous imposerait
volontairement nous nous équipons et
parfois de manière dispendieuse par
exemple d'un smartphone d'un point de
vue grecque cette conception de la
liberté pourrait paraître étrange
lorsque les grecs comptent inventait la
démocratie ils ont pris le pouvoir
qu'ils appartenaient aux tyrans et l'ont
mis au centre de la cité qui est donnée
l'agora de ce pouvoir
chaque citoyen était à égale distance ce
modèle géométrique de la liberté cet
écueil distance de chacun par rapport au
pouvoir
elle avait un nom c'est élise et gaurier
mais en contrepartie d'avoir créé avec
le pouvoir la chose publique
les grecs ont aussi inventé la chose
privée
ils ont inventé ce qu'ils appelaient
l'oeil quo c'est-à-dire le foyer ce qui
reste est intime ce qui restait de
l'ordre aussi de la conscience ou de la
famille de l'un terne et on connaît bien
les grecs pour leur recherche permanente
du jeu
ce milieu ce qu'ils appelaient s'offre
au tuner et les grecs savez bien que la
liberté et la vie privée était
consubstantielle que l'une n'irait pas
sans l'autre d'ailleurs
périclès legrand périclès dans un de ses
discours sur la guerre du péloponnèse
rappeler que cette démocratie et essuie
generis qu'elle était sans précédent
sans antécédent qu'elle était sans
modèle préalable et athènes nous
transmet le lieu d'une utopie cette
utopie de la liberté cette utopie de la
liberté maintes fois contesté dans
l'histoire une utopie dont peut-être
nous avons encore besoin est une utopie
cette utopie il en faut beaucoup car
l'utopie ça réduit à la cuisson sur le
plan de notre modernité économique
on peut également observer l'économie de
l'attention
l'économie de l'attention c'est cette
économie fondée sur la capacité à capter
l'attention du receveur de l'information
l'économie de l'attention est née suite
à la révolution industrielle au début du
xxème siècle dans les années 20 avec les
premières radios l'économie de
l'attention
vous la connaissez déjà sûrement par une
phrase que célèbre que vous avez
sûrement tous entendu déjà qui a été
prononcé par un dirigeant de chaîne de
télévision célèbre qui disait je vends
du serveur du temps de cerveau
disponible temps de cerveau disponible
de ce point de vue là la modernité entre
la radio des années 20 la télévision des
années 80 et google et facebook n'existe
pas
google et facebook sont aussi des
sociétés qui vendent du temps de cerveau
disponible à leurs annonceurs
pour bien comprendre cette économie de
l'attention
je vais prendre un exemple si je vous
dis cacahuètes enrobées de chocolat vous
me dites
ouais merci
mais pourquoi pourquoi ce réflexe
pourquoi cette association
après tout cette espèce de signifiants
et cette sorte de signifier n'ont aucun
rapport ni logique ni pertinent ni
sémantique en quoi que ce soit nous
sommes peut-être là au coeur de ce qu'on
appelle l'économie de l'attention cette
économie de l'attention est en pleine
rivalité aujourd'hui avec le numérique
karl la facilité de produire de
l'information amène une surabondance de
l'offre et nous nous trouvons en pénurie
d'attention
le temps devient une rareté notre
attention devienne une valeur qui
augmente au fur et à mesure qu'il y a de
plus en plus d'informations autrement
dit cette attention se caractérise par
le fait d'avoir mémoriser cacahuètes
enrobées de chocolat et à associer à
eminem ce tour reposent donc sur la
mémoire et au contraire si on oublie
l'association mnm ses cacahuètes
enrobées de chocolat la faillite pour un
manet ns et peut-être au bout du chemin
alors les grecs connaissent très bien ça
pas les harrachis de chocolat thé mais
le la rivalité entre la mémoire et
l'oubli leurs sociétés orales reposer
même sur cette grande rivalité entre
mémoire et oubli
elle avait un nom la mémoire il
l'appelait aletheia et l'oubli il
l'appelait l'été l'été nous le
connaissons c'est le fleuve de l'oubli
que les âmes traverse une fois morte
pour être des fêtes de toutes les
connais quand toutes les connaissances
acquises durant la vie terrestre et afin
de revenir dans un autre cycle
totalement vierge
les poètes été chargée de la mémoire et
de l'oubli les poètes porter cette
parole il faisait de l'un ou de l'autre
des gens qui serait oublier
définitivement dans l'histoire ou de
gens dont on se souviendrait qu'on
aurait mémorisées cette société de
l'attention elle est déjà grec à part
entière d'un côté aletheia était la
lumière la mémoire la louange et l'été
était plutôt la nuit le silence l'oubli
et parmi ces poètes il y en eut teint
qui fit observer quelque chose peut-être
même qui nous met en garde qui était
simone in il était beaucoup plus
célèbres avant si moneda a fait observer
que la louange comportait une part
d'illusions qu'il y avait dans la
louange une part de simulacre et que le
simulacre pouvait être source de
tromperie et de cette manière il
comparait la peinture à la poésie nk en
disant que la peinture était une poésie
qui se tait et la poésie une peinture
qui parle et que nous jouions en
permanence avec des images pour
les différentes réalités qui n'en
étaient pas forcément et de cette
manière
simone in peut nous faire savoir que
notre économie du simulacre notre
économie de la louange ne devrait
peut-être pas faire tomber dans l'oubli
ce qui est essentiel maintenant une
modernité politique
euh pardon scientifique d'un point de
vue scientifique
nous n'avons jamais été aussi moderne ce
n'est pas une révélation
c'est vrai nous avons des algorithmes
qui permettent de calculer des grandes
masses de données
est ce comme jamais auparavant
ces algorithmes et nos ordinateurs en
général fonctionne à partir d'un langage
qu'on appellera langage informatique et
certains voient même dans ce langage
le troisième des grands langage de
l'humanité nous avions un langage pour
la parole qui est devenu l'écrit nous
avions un langage pour les nombres qui
est devenu la monnaie et nous aurions un
langage pour l'informatique qui est
devenu le code informatique
or derrière tout langage il y à bien une
logique cette logique aujourd'hui on
appelle ça une logique binaire une
logique binaire c'est une logique de 1
et 2 0 c'est où un ou zéro
et dans cette logique on peut y
retrouver des logiques plus anciennes
comme par exemple la logique du tir
exclu là il nous suffirait de remonter
le temps assez facilement puisque
aujourd'hui avec cette logique de
mathématiciens cette logique
mathématique au siècle précédent c'était
une logique de physiciens au xviie
siècle ce fut une logique de logicien
mais les prêtres de la période médiévale
l'employeur aussi les orateurs romain
également et au bout de la chaîne on
retrouve encore ces philosophes grecs et
pas le moindre d'entre eux puisque on
retrouve aristote à l'origine de la
logique du tiers exclu en fondant sa
science des syllogismes il a pleinement
utiliser cette loge
du tiers exclu sauf que ce qu'on sait
moins peut-être c'est que aristote se
référer lui-même un poète qu'il faisait
référence dans son invention de la
logique
ce poète était parménide délais et
vivait au vième siècle avant
jésus-christ et il s'exprimait en verre
et il dit un jour lettres et le no
naître n'est pas on retrouve bien le 1 0
en dix ans la part minime délai a fondé
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l'ontologie
c'est à dire la réflexion sur l'être en
général avec un e majuscule et par
rapport à aujourd'hui cette logique qui
est toute mathématique on retrouve la
poésie d'hier
alors que nous dit cette histoire que
nous murmure le vieux poète des âges
anciens et obsolètes
peut-être que les idées ricoche dans
l'histoire peut-être que les idées forme
des cercles concentriques à la surface
de l'histoire est peut-être qu'il suffit
il y à plus de 2500 ans qu'un poète
lance un galet vins et plats pour former
aujourd'hui notre propre modernité
je vous remercie